okay so it turns out that i'm the
substitute speaker for today uh
my collaborator was supposed to give the
talk uh unfortunately couldn't make it
um so this talk will be more of a review
than many of the other talks in this
uh in this workshop
and
so the hope is that uh
i can tell you a little bit about um
how um you know basic
uh condensed metaphysics or in fact
basic physics
basic many body physics
is being influenced by ideas that come
from
quantum information entanglement
entanglement will be the key link
and
so we're hoping that you know some of
these ideas will
uh actually help us understand
uh in greater detail um
what can happen when you take many uh
interacting
quantum particles together uh what are
the uh defining properties of the states
that you uh get in that way okay so um
so let's talk uh i'll start with a
uh you know an introduction on uh using
these slides and then i'll move to the
board when i
actually begin telling you something
that's uh
you know something
more technical
and you know of course feel free to
interrupt with
questions and so on so the idea of this
talk will be to
uh you know really see where the common
points of intersection are
uh and how we can make progress using uh
uh you know using this uh the overlap of
these ideas
okay so i think for this audience
i think the audience has such that
um every uh everything i say will be
completely boring to half of you
so um
but you know given that it's a mixed
audience i think i need to start with
some
uh words of introduction introduction
so i'll start with by telling you about
what we mean by a phase of matter okay
quantum phases matter
and then we'll try to characterize these
phases uh using ideas from
uh
quantum information and quantum
entanglement
okay so
so we're really interested in many
particle systems
and we're interested in the new
phenomena that emerge when you take many
particles together
and
you know you can think about the
properties of one two or three particles
uh but when you get when this number of
particles interacting particles becomes
very large um you should think formally
that it's infinite
uh you get new phenomena okay and we're
interested in interested in
characterizing
these new phenomena so one of the new
phenomena that you get perhaps the most
striking new phenomena is that you get
different phases
okay so by phase
a phase of matter what i mean is that
so you have a particular state
uh of a many particle system you change
your parameters it could be temperature
or pressure or some some other parameter
nothing much happens for a while uh but
then you see something singular happen
yeah i'll give you an example in a
second that's a phase transition we have
some an intuitive understanding of phase
transition and then you go into a
different phase
and if there are two states that are
always separated by such a phase
transition always separated by
a place where the physical properties
become singular you say they are
distinct phases okay so that's an opera
that's sort of a
definition it's not a very useful
definition because
if you have two states you find that
there's some transition between them you
don't know if there's another parameter
along which there is no transition okay
so we look for a definition where
uh the existence of such a singular
point is guaranteed okay a
characterization of these two sides
which is such that there's no way you
can go smoothly from one side to the
other okay and uh you know but this is
an operational definition phases of
matter are states that are always
separated by such a phase transition
okay so you can think about solid and
liquid the more interesting states of
matter for example a superfluid this is
a phase diagram of of helium
and if you uh go across
say change the temperature
and look at what a phase transition
looks like when you go from the super
fluid to the
uh the normal liquid of course we're
down at pretty low temperatures over
here a few kelvin about above absolute
zero you measure some physical property
this turns out to be the specific heat
doesn't really matter what it is
um but what you see is that as you cross
this transition something very very
singular happens okay
anyone could tell that something
happened over here
and that tells you that these two states
are potentially different states of
matter
okay so
for this talk we'll be particularly
interested in quantum phases of matter
so what we'll do is we'll sit at zero
temperature okay so if you think about a
partition function
you weigh the quantum states with this
uh the exponential of the energy divided
by temperature
if i take the temperature to zero you
only look at the lowest energy state
which is the which is the quantum ground
state
okay so we'll be interested in what are
the different ground states of a mini
particle system
where the particles obey laws of quantum
mechanics okay so i'm going to be
restricted
to this axis for example over here and
you can see there's something slightly
more restrictive about a quantum phase
of matter
uh you have superfluid and you have a
solid
but there's no normal liquid over here
okay so it's actually very hard to get a
normal liquid
of bosons if you're down at very low at
zero temperature
okay so the hope is that you can
actually understand
what are the different states of matter
the phases of matter
uh and you know hope to classify them
all
uh and
at least in terms of their
defining properties
and you know to really understand at the
broadest scales what are the different
scale uh states of matter we can get
yeah sorry you see a temperature equals
zero but you still have a temperature in
your uh here's your pressure yeah
so um
so you can you know uh so temperature
equal to zero we're only thinking of the
ground state
uh but if you wish if you're kind of if
you want to start by thinking about a
general finite temperature state as well
you can just think of it as a limiting
case of this partition function
so there's some sort of continuity you
can really think of the temperature when
i say temperature equal to zero
operationally we actually think of
temperature very low rather than zero
yeah sorry for the trivial questions but
but um
what's the reason that you're interested
only why do you call it phases matter
only when there is no way to
go in a
in a smooth way
why doesn't that why did
this is the reason not to call it the
phase of matter yeah so that's a good
question so for example if you look at a
liquid and a gas
so the example i picked was liquid and
solid
i didn't pick liquid on a gas so we're
used to using this terminology of liquid
and gas at different phases
but within my definition actually
they're the same phase
because if you take a liquid on a gas
the distinction between them is only
quantitative
the distinction is really one of density
for example
right and
you know if you take liquid water and
water vapor it looks like there's a
phase transition separating them and
there is i mean if you're at ambient
pressure
but if you really look at the phase
diagram of water in an expanded
parameter space with pressure as well
there's actually a path you can take
where the distinction between the liquid
and the gas gets smaller and smaller and
finally vanishes
so then this part you can take around
that where you never encounter a phase
transition so it turns out this is a
more useful definition of a phase
so we're only looking for some intrinsic
qualitative feature that distinguishes
different states
and if there's a qualitative feature
rather than quantitative
if there's a qualitative feature you can
identify then there's always got to be a
phase transition
so if you think of classifying states
you know you want to focus on the
qualitative features
and for that you really need this
this requirement that there's always a
phase transition between them
so how do you know what are all the
parameters you need to somehow come yes
yes
it sounds crazy yeah so if you were to
think of literally doing this
it's pretty crazy to try to classify
phases of matter but you can think of
certain intrinsic properties that
there's no way you can change in a
continuous wave
and that's how people will classify
that's so i'll give you an example of
how people classified a large set of
states of matter
okay so for a while it was thought that
people had solved this question okay
they had really figured out what are all
the different states of matter
and the the idea was that the different
phases you have different phases for one
single reason and that's because they
have different symmetry
okay so it turns out that was wrong but
you know people made a lot of progress
with just the simple idea
okay so
so what you do is you start with some
system which has a certain symmetry
and as you you know change parameters
the symmetry could be spontaneously
broken in the ground state okay so
although your dynamics your hamiltonian
has a certain symmetry
the ground state may not reflect that
symmetric
okay and then the question of the
different states of matter is just a
question of how many different ways can
you break the symmetry
if this was all there was to
okay so so here's a concrete example
think of
qubits on this lattice or spins on this
lattice they can be either up or down
along the z-axis let's say
there's a coupling that likes to favor
this tends to be parallel or neighboring
sites there's another coupling in the
perpendicular direction this is just
like a field
that tries to scramble the the spins
along the z axis okay
so there's a competition between these
two terms and the
parameter the tunes between them is g
okay so this hamiltonian has a symmetry
you can reverse all the spins in the z
direction
and that doesn't change the hammer turn
okay so there's a
z2 symmetry after down snapping there's
an operator that induces the symmetry
which commutes to the hamiltonian
okay so you would think that you can
label all of your states by this
uh quantum numbers of this operator
so all of the states would all of the
eigen states of the simultaneous would
be symmetric
and that's true for any finite number of
particles any finite number of spins but
when you take the number of spins to
infinity
it turns out that
a pair of these
when you're in the limit where this term
dominates you can actually think of a
state where all of the spins are lying
along the certain z along the say the
plus z direction okay so
so you have two phases
okay so g is very large
the spins are along x they don't favor
either plus or minus c the symmetry is
preserved but if i make g very small
your
dominated by this ferromagnetic term
which likes to align the spins um and
eventually the spins will pick either to
order all up or down
okay and so there's an order parameter
and this
there's a there's a
something that you can do to to see that
this matter is broken you can simply
take the expectation value of
the the spin operator in the z direction
okay and there's a ground there is a
ground state uh where this expectation
value is nonzero okay clearly this
breaks the symmetry because the symmetry
is taking all the suspense from z to
minus c spontaneously picks either
upward now
and this can only occur in the limit of
a very large number of sides in assist
okay so it's really this distinction if
you had a finite system there's no
distinction over here everything is
smooth as a function of the square meter
g
when you take the limit of n going to
infinity there's going to be a phase
transition something singular that
happens over here
and you can see there's no way to avoid
the singularity as long as your
hamiltonian has symmetric
okay there's a clear-cut definition of
something that's broken symmetry a
clear-cut definition of a symmetric
preserving state uh you're either one or
the other
there's no way to kind of be confused
the only way you can go around is if you
were to
explicitly break the symmetry of the
same time sorry
you're saying the symmetry is broken
because you can't be
for large numbers you cannot be in a
superposition
yeah that's one way to say it yeah so
strictly speaking you could also pick a
state that is
you know a superposition maybe it's good
to point that out at this point because
this caveat may come up later so
strictly speaking in a finite size
system you're you have a superposition
of
all up and all down
you can have the plus or minus
combination
and these are the two eigen states of
the system okay the lowest energy eigen
states the limit of the z being very
large
okay but uh this is like a schrodinger
can stick okay this is a microscopic
number of spins all pointing up are all
pointy now
okay you can just tell from the
magnetization whether it's this or that
it can't really be in the superposition
state you'll never be able to maintain
the coherence of the superposition so
it's more reasonable to say that it
collapses into one of these states
and the limit of very large number of
particles the splitting between these
two states vanishes okay so you have a
pair of states in any finite number of
particles and they become exactly
degenerate in the end going to infinity
limit
the number of spencer infinity limit
okay and then it's your choice what
superposition of these you take and call
your ground state
and the reasonable thing to do is to
take this particular superposition
the one where all the spins are all up
or down
okay there's a different way of thinking
about this which is to look instead of
just directly at this order parameter to
look at a correlation function okay so
you look at two sides i and j
that are let's say very far apart
and you ask what is the
probability that this
side the spell on side j is up if the
spin on side is up okay this expectation
value in the ground state
okay and you can show that when you're
in this um
in this part of the phase diagram this
goes to a constant uh even though the
separation between these
sides goes to infinity
okay the advantage of this definition is
that it doesn't really require you to be
in a particular superposition over here
take any sort of position you like
tap the property that the strings are
aligned whether you're here or there or
at the eastern position
and this is a signal that something
weird has happened you take spins very
very far away they know what the other
spin is doing
and sort of the reasonable thing to say
is that
the spins themselves have an expectation
that
and that's why you see this correlation
okay but this is an equally good
diagnostic you can distinguish the two
phases
by looking at the correlation function
at very large separations
and then you don't need to answer the
question of what superposition you're at
of course large separation means that
you have an infinite system
right and that's where this large number
of spins comes
okay so this will be called the order
parameter when it's non-zero you know
you're in the symmetric dropping phase
okay so
so it turns out once you have a theory
based on the sort of parameter you can
do a number of things
you can for example classify all
possible states just a question of how
the different ways in which you can
break this you identify the symmetries
of your original hamiltonian and think
of all the different ways in which they
can be broken
okay so for example people classified
how you can break this translation
symmetries of space and to get go from a
liquid to a solid because that's really
what distinguishes the two and you find
that there are only 200
only
230 ways of doing it right
and so any crystal you find in nature if
it's you know has
this sort of broken symmetry it's going
to be one of those 230 types okay
so you have a complete classification of
different states
uh this also gives you a way to tell
which phase you're in you can go and
measure this order parameter okay it's
very natural thing to measure there are
experiments like neutron scattering for
example that will measure this
particular parameter
you can go
and tell so in fact people have gone and
identified some
natural
naturally occurring mineral in each one
of these 230 space groups okay so if you
give me a
chunk of rock i can tell you which of
this 238 belongs to by doing some
experiment
okay so it's a local you make a local
measurement to tell which state you're
in
okay and it also tells you it gives you
a way to construct the theory of the
phase transition it's really how this
number 5
goes from being zero to being something
non-zero
and clearly that's yeah
so
you sort of
you made them equal this definition and
the previous definition but this takes
in this sort of says that that the
ground states are distinguished by local
properties
yeah yeah
you don't take into account
uh global like topological order that's
right yeah so this is an incomplete
classification people didn't realize
that but yeah it's an incomplete
classification yeah
yeah so uh and in a way it's kind of
nice that it's incomplete because
there's something disappointing about
this if this was all there's something
disappointing about it
so essentially this auto parameter is
like a classical object
right so it's
sort of saying that all of your
particles are condensed in one
particular quantum state and then that
becomes a classical state okay so even
very exotic states of matter like
superfluid that has an order parameter
superfluous sounds like some very exotic
quantum state okay but actually it's a
very classical state it's simply a state
where
the wave nature of of matter is
emphasized
okay so you take all of these atoms
helium atoms and a superfluid put them
in a single quantum state of one
particle
then that quantum state becomes
classical it's sort of like
you know light is a wave and we think of
it as a classical wave for most purposes
okay so once you get over this sort of
idea that atoms are particles if you're
allowed to think about their wave nature
and only their wave nature
then the superfluidity becomes a very
classical phenomenon
okay the things that are most quantum
are ones where you cannot think of them
as either wave or particle right
so it's sort of a weird state but it is
a very classical state
okay so uh
so states that are described like this
using an order parameter you've taken a
lot of quantum particles and put them
together but the many body system that
you get the thing that you ultimately
end up with is actually quite classical
and in fact if you look at the
entanglement
that characterizes these phases you can
find a representative state that lives
in each of these phases where all of the
entanglement is very short-ranged
okay so for example um you know this
ferromagnet we talked about
in the previous slide you can simply
think of it as a product state of all of
the spins being up
okay there's really no entanglement
between neighboring spins that's the
caricature of this ferromagnetic state
okay so the hope is that there are other
phases of matter where the entanglement
is not short-range
so
um
it seems like you want to restrict your
discussion to zero temperature correct
yeah yeah because of course this process
particular sometimes changes depending
on the temperature that's right yeah but
so would you is it the correct point of
view that to classify our classical
states because you were like for example
point one that this the discussion
restricting yourself to t is zero
suffices
is that
even though the elect you know electrons
are at low temperature but i mean or do
you really need to
yeah so when you're when you're really
at zero temperature um
certain classical states are hard to
realize certain finite temperature
states are hard to realize but you get
other states as well for example if you
have
uh you know for example the statistics
of the particles begins to matter when
you're at very low temperatures
um so so kind of restricted to quantum
states to quantum
uh
ground states because that would be kind
of the simple yeah you start yeah a
simple thing you start from um
i think pretty much all of the states
okay there are one or two exceptions but
pretty much all of the states that we
will
discuss as quantum ground states
you can think of it as a classical state
in a high one higher dimension
so there is a close connection there are
some quantum states that you cannot
think like that but
uh pretty much all the classical states
can be related in that way to some
quantum state
uh so there will be some connections
that uh
right but i mean
my feeling is that to to describe if you
say well contest matter systems as you
know as we know it finite temperature
you do also need to look at the you know
what symmetries are still broken at
finite temperature yeah yeah that's
right that's right yeah yeah
so so
so there are some symmetries which um
you know for example this if i take this
system up to finite for another axis of
a finite temperature axis this broken
symmetry will persist to finite
temperatures
but there are other cases where if i
took a one dimensional example of this
you've got to find a temperature
symmetry is bond
yeah so you can think of actually
temperature as one more uh parameter if
you like it's not that different from
having another parameter
it's a special kind of parameter but
it's another one
okay so so other examples which don't
fall into this
into this uh way of thinking and yeah
you could come up with a very simple
model
uh which you know which is clearly
outside
uh this way of thinking yeah so i want
to clarify on the last slide so you said
for these ordered systems you have short
range and tangle numbers yeah there is a
caricature state which has short range
entanglement there's a state and that's
phase
which has short range entanglement okay
now because you put a cat seat on the
board there so
this is why it was
yeah and you know if you look at a
generic state even if you're in this
can't stay in in one of these uh
states if you go away from the special
point where
the
the
zzz interaction dominates you'll get
some quantum fluctuations so it's not
like it's zero entanglement between the
sides
but i can you know i can always find
this cartoon state which has zero
entanglement
for that phase but there are other
phases where it's not like that you
even the cartoon state will have some
non-trivial long-range entanglement
yeah and so that's the hope that you
know quantum particles will give you
something in quantum when you think
about a many-body system
okay so here's an example of a model
where we'll show that there are two
phases that have no symmetry distinction
between them okay
so it looks suspiciously like the
previous model but it's actually
different we still have spin a half on
the sides of a square lattice
here or cubits and sets of square
lattice but the interaction will be of
this form so around the blue black hat
that's you take the product of the z
z uh
spin operators around this other black
educate the product of the x spin
operators okay and then to break all
symmetries i'll add various terms you
can actually add any term you like as
long as it's small
and they're going to change the physics
much let me add these terms that for
example break this
z2 symmetry okay so this model is no
symmetry
uh but it has two phases
okay so you know for example uh if you
people have numerically figured out the
phase diagram of this model as a
function of these two parameters h
and they find that there's a face here
and a phase there
so what is the distinction between these
phases so now they're really distinct
phases
okay so this would be a surprise if you
thought that the only distinction
between phases is based on symmetry okay
you might think that there's some other
axis where you can go from here to there
okay but in fact these are really
distinct phases and there's a way to
understand them
okay so you can go to the special point
where you turn off those fields
and
so then you only have these two terms
and these terms actually commute with
one another this is the story code
hamilton in which many of you are
probably familiar with
and there's a nice way of displaying the
ground state of this model where you
make both of these terms equal to unity
okay so
so what you do is you think about a
lattice that's
i guess a dual lattice which is a
rotated 45 degrees
and wherever this
will work in the basis where the sigma z
is either plus or minus one um
and if the sigma z is minus one i'm
going to put a line on this uh over here
here on this on this length
okay now of course to satisfy this
particular term uh you need that around
every bracket
uh actually maybe i i probably want
maybe i want sigma x equal to minus one
being by lines sorry
so so let my lines be sigma x equal to
minus 1
then at every one of these vertices over
here
in order to satisfy this particular term
i'm going to get an even number of of
lines coming out
okay so this is a model where um
you know your you have these loops
uh where you can use either one of these
representations uh you have these loops
where um
so the ground state is composed of these
loops and these loops cannot end because
those are the low energy configurations
okay and then you have a quantum
superposition of all of these loop
configurations with equal weight
okay so that's a caricature for the
ground state
and
the question is how does this ground
state
differ from the ground state for example
the more trivial ground state for
example where one of these fields
dominates
okay where all of the spins are lined in
some direction
okay so that will be the main
part of my talk how we can try to
characterize
such phases okay so
so these are phases which uh you know
for example when i'm in this
in this particular
phase
these are going to be gap phases
and the thing that will be distinct
between
a ground state that looks like this and
one that is trivial will be that there's
something topologically different
okay and so what we we hope to do is to
sort of emulate the success
of
that people had with
phases that simply broke a symmetry okay
so what is the analog of an order
parameter
here's something that will allow us to
characterize the distinction between
these phases
and you know also hopefully be able to
measure it and you know do all the other
good things that you could do with the
order parameter
okay so in some sense this is still an
open question i would say
yeah yeah can i ask a question about
that because you could say well i want a
parameter which distinguishes whether
i'm in the top logic or non-topological
thing
but of course if you just have the icing
fair magnesium you have a parameter that
this does something more it's
imagination also tells you whether it's
up here or in the you know up magnet it
makes it positive or not that's right so
to me
in that discussion because you know like
for the throw code you can write down
not an order parameter with an order
observable which i think is nonzero in
the topological phase
which if you measure it
this determines you know it it's it's a
logical operator it measures uh you know
what state you're in and the expectation
value of these operators will always be
zero in the non-topological phase
but it's not a single parameter
but i i so so there are other people
that looked at a single parameter or you
say well wait i want an operator
yeah yeah so this is sort of a vague
question right we want to do something
as useful as an order parameter for
topological phases yeah and there are
many answers to this question and i
think the answer that will finally
kind of stay will be the one that's most
useful
so i'll try to argue that actually the
good way to think about this is using
entire method
so it's a point many people have made
but
uh phase is not just the torah code but
a whole
bunch of phases of that kind
we'll be able to use entanglement not
only to tell you which state itself
whether it's in the trivial or the
topological phase but to also completely
characterize this topological phase
and so so the nice thing about
so many other answers you could give
right so so how do i tell the fan in
this topological phase um so what are
the what are its properties
um
okay so um
so i think i'm not going to use the
computer anymore so maybe i should just
shut it down
okay so uh
so very broadly we're interested in
phases of matter that have long range of
time okay and um
okay so i'll only be talking about a
very narrow
subset of these phases
which have an energy curve
okay
and i'll mainly talk about two
dimensional phases in two spatial
dimensions
so i'm leaving out a lot of stuff of
course i'm leaving out very interesting
gapless phases of matter maybe i'll have
time to say a few words about that
and phases in different dimensions here
the different dimensions is not that
important because once you focus on gap
phases
some of the most interesting states are
in two dimensions
okay so
okay so so we want to know first the
first question we'd like to answer is
how do i tell them whether i'm in this
this ground state or something that is
in the same phase as this ground state
which is a sum over all of these loop
configurations
closed loop configurations
or
trivial state
okay
so it turns out that this
state over here
is a very interesting state
which is which people sort of knew in
some language before
which is sort of a deconfined
phase
okay so what do we mean by that
you can look at the excitations in the
system
and
the excited states are simply loops for
example which end
okay so if you have a loop
okay so state where
there are some endpoints
of this loop and then of course you sum
over all other loop configurations
keeping these end points fixed okay so
there will be another configuration
which is in the quantum super position
we have a little loop somewhere else and
so on uh but this is a state which has a
pair of these excitations located at
these two points
okay the thing that's special about this
phase is that it costs you only a finite
energy to separate out these ends of
strings
okay so normally if i told you there was
a
state where
i have points which are at the ends of
strings
a typical hamiltonian would give you
some energy cost for the string
and as you separate out these
points the energy cost will increase
with the length of the string
if you can observe the string it means
the hamilton you can observe it as well
and it'll end up giving an energy cost
per unit length
okay so this gives you an energy that
increases linearly with the separation
which basically means these particles
can't come apart
okay so that's called the confined phase
that's really what happens in the huge
in the trivial phase okay where this the
fields are large
okay so uh so the special thing about
this uh ground state is that because of
this quantum superposition you can't
really observe the string
if there are quantum fluctuations that
you can talk about the location of these
endpoints but you can't really tell
where the string is
okay so the quantum uncertainty has
moved the string around so it's gone
it's disappeared into the soup
so you can't really find an object to
give an energy per unit length
okay so the energy cost of separating
these is is actually finite
you pay an energy cost and then it
doesn't matter how far far apart we are
you get some new excitations essentially
okay in this phase which are the ends of
steps here there's another excitation
which are these so we worked on a
particular representation uh
unfortunately i wrote it wrong in mind
and i think these loops are actually
where the sigma x is minus one of those
bonds it is another excitation where you
take a paquette
and flip or take this product of sigma z
around this packet
and flip it sign
okay so let me draw it as some shaded
packet
okay so these are the two kinds of
excitations the ends of strings and
these shaded packets they both both
cause planet energy they're not there on
the ground state
okay so there's a
phase that you get when you take one of
these around the other
there's a phase of minus one
okay there's some
mutual statistics if you like
so basically this object over here looks
like a charge
and this looks like some sort of flux
okay and this phase is just an arduino
bomb phase of taking a charge around a
flux
okay so that's the defining property of
the state
uh two kinds of excitations with this
mutual minus one phase factor very space
factor on from taking one around the
other okay and that just follows from
the anti-commutation of these uh poly
matrices you can kind of
it's not hard to guess that you take
some string
you take some plucket and you take one
around the other you get some minus one
somewhere
okay so so that's if you like one way of
diagnosing this phase okay you go and
make these excitations
you find the space of excitations take
one around the other
measure this berries face and that's a
way to get at the new physics in this in
the state
okay
uh
so of course that's uh you know not uh
very convenient
um
but and it involves excited states so
you can make one more restriction all of
the physics should be in the ground
state
okay just looking at ground state
properties can you tell me uh which of
these two phases you're in
okay this this one or the trivial one
and that's what happens with the order
parameter definition we have there's a
local measurement you can do with ground
yeah yes so in this particular case of
this string
if you're in that confined phase you
could also not see the string so i don't
see because you say like that particular
now in the confined phase you actually
see the string that's why the string is
short there is no string in some sense
no it's it's like
you can just have two accelerations
yeah but there'll be a defect line
running
so the excitations are taking this uh if
you make this kind of excitation
you know by definition this excitation
is the end of the string
so if you if you want an algebraic
definition of this excitation you take a
product of these sigma x operators along
the line yeah okay
yeah and that's always there actually in
any phase you can make this excitation
it's just that the energy cost of making
this extinction is just going up to the
separation
so if you look at a fine you know look
at low energy states they won't appear
or at any any reasonable distance
they'll only appear as bound pairs
yeah so these are electrical charge if
you like you can think of these as
quarks right these are quarkx stations
in the deconfined phase you can really
drag the quarks apart you'll see
frequency in the confined phase they're
all bonded very tightly together and you
only see combinations of quarks like
mesons or something
so
and this linear confinement is very
obvious over here
why the energy increases linearly with
the separation is simply because there's
a string running between that and what
happens that if you kind of go away from
the total code you have to fatten that
kind of yeah there are fluctuations yeah
but ultimately if you look at long
distances this is the physics
as you know this is the fixed point wave
function so if you're really looking at
a defining property of the phase you
look at physics at very long distances
uh and then you're back to the simple
picture
so what you're getting okay
what's the importance of the hx is equal
to 0.2 and h
equal to the point where the transition
occurs yeah i mean
so yeah that's detail i think in that
particular model it's uh where they i
know but
what sort of what's happening
yeah what's happening yeah yeah yeah
good question yeah against each other
yeah yeah so i said this ground state is
a bunch of closed loops
uh but actually there are some
probability of getting an open loop as
well that's the ground state and this
limit where i don't have any of the h
stuffs
uh if i add in these h terms it
generates little
open loop segments
uh and they're only they're small to
begin with so if i look at long
distances i don't really see the the
open loop segments but at some point
they proliferate
uh they become longer and longer and
that kills the phase you can no longer
characterize your face it's just being
closed loops so it's something like
percolation of those yeah yeah yeah but
they're interacting in some way so the
actual the weird thing is the transition
if you look at the physics of that
transition it's the same as the
transition in the other model i showed
you
the icing transaction
the physics of the you know the
universal physics is the same for some
weird reason but uh yeah
yeah sorry i think yeah
so everything you told us so far one
except for the very phase you could say
about a classical system like spin-ups
you get the confinement deconfinement
yeah
nothing to do with entanglement that's
right yeah yeah
what is what is fundamentally quantum
mechanical yeah
yeah so
actually i think this this particular
example probably has a classical analog
it's just not very natural i mean
you can think of a three-dimensional
version of this which is a statistical
mechanics model but i'll characterize it
using entanglement and then that also
works for other phases which have no
classical analog like these chiral
states the fractional quantum on states
yeah so this is sort of
some points over here i think have
classical analogs but if you think of
the entire set then it's uh it's really
quantum mechanical i think
and do you have a question yeah so in
that model you were just showing on the
on the presentation you had to see
single x and z perturbations right they
were turned down
but of course you i think you're
probably claiming that doesn't matter so
much yeah it just matters where the
facebook is but this behavior is not
being able to see the string or not
that's right yeah yeah that's sort of
the
amazing thing about this model you can
add any term you like actually i took a
particular model but if your the
dominant
terms are like this the product of z's
and x add any old term you like that's
local
and it's not going to kill the face so
you know i think when you at least
when i teach uh quantum statistical
mechanics you should start with this
model there's no assumption of symmetry
or anything you just take any
old model which okay you pushed it into
a particular parameter regime uh to get
this interesting phase but this is the
fundamental distinction between phases
and then if you have symmetry there's
some further distinction of whether
symmetry is broken or not
but yeah
so i didn't understand what you said so
you bet you said basically that this has
a classical analog
in 3d
yeah if you think of time as a as a
spatial direction so think of time as a
spatial direction
then it turns out this if you look at
the imaginary time partition function
uh this actually defines a classical
model
a three-dimensional classical model
which has some analogous obviously you
can read off this dictionary to go
between the transfer model yeah but you
don't i mean there are properties of the
torah code that
that are completely quantum that's right
yeah yeah moving around yeah that's the
thing you're saying the very phases yeah
right but presumably given that there's
a dictionary there's some
not natural property in the statement
mode which corresponds to that
right of course there are no phases in
the stackmic model
but you can the imaginary time partition
function is you can interpret it as a
stat mic partition function in three
dimensions
so
the physics is somewhere there
it has two phases it has one phase where
the loops are big and one phase where
they're not and so on so can i interpret
this as if the
topological order in in the torah code
is not
in some sense really
quantum or i mean yeah but i think the
some sense is not a very natural sense
it's classical in some other dimension
right it's not that it the model itself
is classical there's some reflection in
a different model which is classical
and maybe you guys have some better
answers doesn't necessarily follow that
it has an interpretation of the
classical partition function it only has
an interpretation as a classical
partition function
all the exponents are close to it yeah
this one it does
yeah
which also depends on which basis you
pick i can find a basis probably where
it doesn't have a natural position yeah
yeah yeah yeah but you can presumably
add terms and make it more generic and
you're still in the same phase
because for example if you look at the
quark
wave function
function
yeah yeah that's right
yeah but you know if i just think of the
classical partition function
right um
yeah it's going to be the zero
temperature class you know the partition
function for the zero temperature phase
but i think that's not the same as
changing the wave function
it's really changing parameters
of the hamiltonian and looking at the
ground state that's what the
three-dimensional partition point but
okay let's talk about this maybe later
i want to tell you that this was not a
good way of characterizing the
or at least not the one i want if you
have dynamics of course you have the
full control picture now there's no
classical work of it
depends what your damage depends what
exactly the dynamics are but
if you have no sign problem you can
still
uh reduce some classical handling
resolution not real time yeah that's
really good yeah that's good yeah yeah
if you're looking at real time
properties then you're right that's
completely different
just the ground state properties that
have a classical analog
okay so so the other other ways in which
we can characterize this
phase
and
you know so one thing that is
that was known for a long time
is
okay so the ground states are degenerate
depending on the topology of your space
okay so for example if you define this
model on a torus which is just making
periodic boundary conditions
uh
for this first
sample
for this particular model you have
foreground states
and a physical picture of this why you
get this degeneracy is that you can
insert these flux lines
we said that there are these magnetic
flux loops you can insert them through
the holes of the stoves
okay you can think of it like that so if
i don't measure the flux from going
around one of these cycles
you measure this flux of -1
but since this flux doesn't pierce the
surface there's no energy penalty for it
okay so the flux fluxes that are inside
the where there's no matter where
there's no model defined
uh you see that in the long loops of
this torus
um but you know there's no energy
penalty for it okay
and the only way you can tell which of
these four ground states you're in is to
take a charge and go around
one of the the cycles of the stores
okay and of course that's a highly
non-local
measurement uh it requires to go a long
way if you think of a big system
uh and which is why these things are
degenerate okay the hamiltonian itself
can't tell which state you're that's why
they all have the same energy
okay so that's another way people knew
of characterizing these
phases
but you know more recently this is like
maybe six seven years back
people realize that there's a signature
and entanglement entropies
okay so uh
so if you just look at one so the nice
thing about this measure is that you
just give me one ground state
and
you you think of
taking separating this into two parts
a and a bar and as everyone here knows
you can calculate the entanglement
entropy
um
for this i'm only going to look at your
states
and we'll stick with the one nominal
entropy
although for many of the things i'll say
it doesn't really depend on whether you
use the one normal entropy or one of the
random entropies where you take the
power of this density matrix test
okay so uh
so the entanglement entropy doesn't
matter it doesn't care about whether you
trace out the inside or the outside
and typically for gap phases
okay so question mark because we heard a
talk yesterday saying that this may not
be true there's an area law
it's many of the examples we know
there's an area law
so it depends on the parameter over here
and some number
okay so of course at this stage
this doesn't really distinguish
different gap phases
but what people figured out um
okay so one way to to to summarize what
they found is that there is a subleating
term
in this entanglement entropy
which carries information on whether
this phase is topological or not
okay there's a
a term that's independent
of size
we're always assuming that la is very
large
so really exploring the intrinsic
properties of the phase
the fact that you have the subleading
term
is
if the subleading term is nonzero
it tells you that you're in a
topological phase
okay so this is sort of a good way of
stating the results
there are many caveats that come with
if you want this
if you want this to be rigorously true
and stated in this fashion
okay but this is essentially the
idea that there is
something over here
some modification of the entanglement
entropy which tells you that you have
long range entanglement
okay and for the particular case that we
talked about for the torah code
okay there's one bit of enzyme
sorry yeah so
but here you seem to be saying that that
you know in terms of the area on
you know your your
entropy bound is so exact across all
boundaries that you can even detect yes
so how true is that i mean okay so i can
give you something which is maybe a
little more satisfying yeah um which is
uh don't you know so what this is
telling you is to actually scale the
uh do this measurement
find the subleading term take a bigger
one do the same thing
um so it sounds first of all impractical
you're separated out of a constant from
this and also it's not your white's
topological right why can't some regular
phase give me some camera
um
so uh so okay i wanted to discuss both
of these things first of all people have
actually used this to identify phases so
it's not crazy as a practical tool
and second question why is it
topological
so one way of rephrasing this which is
more obviously topological is to take
the following construction this is due
to these two people
instead of taking just a single
you know region that you cut out
let me take three regions
that's region a that's region b
and that's regions
okay so now i can look at the
entanglement entropy of either one of
these regions or some combination
uh so let me look at
the following combination
first i take all three regions
okay i cut those out i've calculated the
entanglement entropy okay these are
supposed to be
adjacent okay so you abc looks like like
that
okay this is abs
okay then you look at the contribution
from b
and then you take out the contribution
from a b and
okay so form this combination okay the
claim is that this thing is um i think
it's minus two cameras
yeah it's matched together yeah so uh so
why is this more obviously topological
so the way this thing is set up
is that if i make any small changes
to these regions
uh you can show that this answer is not
going to change
okay for example let's say i take this
region a
and
turn it into a slightly different region
like that
okay that's going to change the
entanglement entropy of sabc
okay
but
the contribution you get from s a b is
going to exactly cancel that
okay the reason is s a b and s a b c
only differ and whether or not you're
adding this region c
can in a system that's gapped if all of
these lengths are very large that's an
exponentially small correction and
exponential in this separation
okay so basically the number of very
large systems there's no real
distinction between
uh the change in the entropy due to
adding this region in this term
and in laptop so they exactly cancel
okay so you can go on and do all these
you know you can worry about these
corners over here maybe change over here
how does that cancel out and so on you
can convince yourself none of those
things actually change this result
okay so this is really a topological
statement so if you show it for
one bunch of boundaries for one
particular
realization of the state
you know it's going to be robust as long
as this energy gap is maintained
and you have this topology
okay so uh
am i out of time now almost or
it's too interesting to even move
so you're saying it's practical and do
you really mean that people have
measured
yeah that they have
systems
so i think the first measurement was
matt and his collaborators used quantum
monte carlo the stochastic way of
measuring it within a model that didn't
have a sound problem where
they're probably experimentally oh
that's amazing
so it's all numerical measurement stuff
yes but i mean is there are there ideas
because that's still challenging
yeah so experimentally even to measure
entanglement entropy
to measure this is already a challenge
but i think people have ideas how to do
that
not the topological entanglement entropy
because the zeroth order problem is you
don't have a topological phase yet
something that's clearly topological in
an experiment
but just measuring the entanglement
entropy there are there are pretty good
ideas actually which
uh you know at least in these cold atom
systems i think it's just a matter of
time for people measure in some cases
somewhere
but numerically this has been very
useful there are some models where we
actually the tour report is obvious this
is a different state there are some
models we are not sure what that state
is and
this is actually pinned down
uh at least in one case
uh that you have some the same
topological orders as the story code
okay so let me give you one argument
before i think i'm probably run out of
time why even having something like this
is a topological um
you know means that you have long range
entirely okay it's sort of a heuristic
argument but at least for me it was very
useful
uh to understand why certain terms even
though it's a bleeding term uh tells you
something interesting is going on
okay so one of the assumptions you make
when you have this sort of so by the way
if you use this
way of writing the entanglement entropy
you can convince yourself
that this configuration this combination
over here will give you 2gam
so you get a gamma for every
boundary that you have
and if you look at the difference over
here this is a
system that has two boundaries
whereas these have one boundary each
so the difference will be two gamma
yeah is it uh so that abc loop um if
you're measuring it on a torque code for
instance or like a it's actually on a
torus does it matter if that
uh that abc loop is sort of trivial or
not trivial yeah it matters that was
going to be something i was going to
talk about uh because this is all like
seven six seven years old that's sort of
the more
recent stuff and
uh
yeah but i think i probably don't have
time to get there
okay so one interesting thing to point
out is this combination over here
is actually this uh the same combination
that appears in the statement of strong
subjectivity
okay so strong supportivity says that we
look at the entanglement entropy of some
two regions let me call it let's call it
x and y so you don't get confused with
this
x and y and take out as x y
x intersection y and s
x union y
okay so this is always
greater than or equal to 0.
and if you call x a b and y
bc
okay you can show that this strong
subjectivity relation tells you that
this gamma must be positive
or non-negative
so there's some deep connection between
this topological entanglement entropy
and
the strong subactivity okay so
it tells you actually more than that
which is related to this question
uh which is what the topological
entanglement entropy looks like on the
torus and it gives you sort of
uncertainty relations
between the gammas you get going around
the two cycles of the stones
so whether this is this cycle or that
cycle you get
some relation between the gammas again
related with strong severity
okay but uh anyway let me give you this
uh argument and finish which is why this
so actually yeah i got permission to
extend it
which is how much seven ten minutes
if that will help in covering the next
seven years
yeah
so um
uh okay so maybe there are two basic
arguments i can make first which
and and then get to this
the more recent thing which is
uh so the first thing is why is why is
it log2 for the story code
and why is this thing really topological
okay so why is it log 2 for the torah
code there's a very simple answer that
you can give to that
so if you look at the ground state wave
function for the turret code it's all
these closed loops okay so if you're
looking at some region a
and then you have all of these closed
loops that intersect it and you have
loops of all different sizes you have
small loops big loops and that's it's
important that you have
all different kinds of loops when you
cut these loops
depending on what the configuration of
this
these loops are that they intersect the
region
the boundary of this region
that gives you the different schmidt
states okay so if you like
the entanglement entropy comes from the
boundary and
the boundary degrees of freedom are
really the ways in which this
these loops intersect the bond
okay so
so if you think about this entanglement
entropy as
the ignorance of your
ignorance you have when you cut out this
the outside
all of these
positions where
the loop can cut the boundary give you
one bit of ignorance
right
so naively you would say that this
the entropy is log of the number of
sites on the boundary
okay so so that's a naive answer that
gives you the the area of
the boundary law
okay but actually you know a little bit
more than you might think
which is that you have no idea how many
times these loops will cut your boundary
but you know it's got to be an even
number of times
okay so you're not as ignorant as you
think you are
you have some information
okay so actually you
uh
you know the the true amount of
information you have is
uh
basically one bit of information you
know whether you know that it's even
rather not okay so this gives you
a subleading term that's independent of
how many sides you have on the boundary
so if in terms of this connection to
gauge theory this is like gauss's law
the fact that you have closed loops
loops are like electric fields and
divergence of the electric field has to
be zero there are no charges so gauss's
law always gives you this it's a
constraint
so you don't fluctuate as much as you
think so you get this contribution with
language entropy that lowers the entropy
because you actually know a little bit
more
and your knowledge is just one bit
here which is really the top logical and
time potential
so in these settings it's very simple
okay it's
it's really a question of knowing that
there are no no charges inside this
region gives you a constraint which
gives you this result
okay so the second thing is why is this
written in this fashion why is this
topological
or why does it mean that there's long
range entanglement this way of writing
it is obvious
okay so why is it topological in this
way of writing it so what you can do is
you can think about
writing the total entanglement entropy
of your
system
as being composed of some
little segments
so the entropy coming from little
segments over here adding them all up
okay so that's an assumption
if you have something that's short-range
entangled you think you can write down
the total entanglement entropy as simply
as sum of some local contributions
okay to actually prove that it requires
strong assumptions that
like the entanglement hamiltonian being
locals but you know let's just make this
assumption this just means a short range
impact
so we want to verify that you don't get
a constant like this when it's
short-range entangled it really is a
manifestation of some long-range
entanglement okay so we want to show
that if i make this assumption then this
gamma is zero
okay so so let's say you take a very
small segment over here so in order for
this to be precise you need that you're
in the continuum limit okay there's no
lattice that you can see
everything is homogeneous
and you're thinking about a smooth
boundary
okay so you want to know what is the
contribution
from some segment over here some some
little segment okay so let me write that
as some
some differential contribution
uh now of course this thing can have
some uh
actually that's d s by e we just
understand this
okay this can have some
constant part that just tells you that
there's some entanglement over here
and then there are corrections to this
uh which will depend just on the shape
of this function
okay so if i have just a one dimensional
segment the only parameter that tells
you what is shaped as the curvature
there's like a radius of curvature that
you can write for the segment
so there's a curvature which is
essentially one over this radius
okay so you can think of making some
expansion in terms of the curvature
there's a constant and then there's some
maybe some curvature term and then
there's some curvature squared term
it could also be derivatives of
the curvature with respect to this uh
segment and so on
okay but there should be some sort of
curvature expansion
when you
just look at the contribution of the
entanglement from a little segment
that's the only property it has
okay now if this was the expansion and
you integrate this curvature integrate
this contribution around the loop this
first term as is dimensionless so when
you integrate it will get something
proportional to length
the second term is dimensions of one
overlap
it gets a radius it's one over the
radius of curvature
so if you were to integrate it you would
get a constant
and all these other terms would give you
subletting contributions okay so if this
term was present
it's bad news because it will tell you
that even a short range entangled phase
can give you some
constant contribution
you know it turns out this term is is
actually forbidden
uh because of this property of the
entitlement entropy right there is it
this called here
okay the entanglement of the inside and
the outside of the segment
so in terms of curvature if you looked
at the segment from the outside it has
the opposite
radius of curvature okay so when you go
from inside to outside
there's a symmetry that takes kappa to
minus kappa
okay but the entanglement entropy can't
change so this term is going to be
absent anything that's odd
uh in under this uh symmetry must be
absent
uh so you don't get this constant
okay so that's why this constant is
actually telling you something weird is
going on
it's not simply a sum of contributions
around this loop
okay so so it turns out that all of
these gap topological phases can be
characterized
by this number
okay but it doesn't give you a complete
characterization of the phase unlike a
an order parameter
okay so
okay so so a big open question is if i
give you just one ground state
can you completely characterize the top
logical audit not just by this one
number there is a set of numbers that
completely characterize your topological
fix
okay so we know how to do it is if you
give me all the ground states on a
tourist
if there's a way to do this if you give
me for example in this case give me the
four ground states on the torus there's
a way to completely characterize the
topological order using quantum
entanglement
okay and
but it should be possible actually at
one ground state and that's not known
yet
okay so so that's i think maybe i should
end over there there's an even for this
very simple set of gap phases there's an
open question of
uh
you know how one completely
characterizes it
uh this gammas gives you a lot of
information but in fact there are two
topological phases which are the same
log to entanglement
uh
two related you know but distinct
topological phases
which have this logical entanglement and
four degenerate ground states on the
doors
and to tell them apart it's a question
of whether this phase factor is -1 or
phase factor of i when you take one of
these particles around the other
so that's you know that complete
characterization of the second ground
state is not yet understood
so anyway so uh so let alone
gapless phases whereas
they're already interesting questions
when you're talking about characterizing
gapped phases of matter which have
longer
yeah
just on that last point i i think of a
third one as well as the non-abelian
thing yeah that's why i said foreground
states
from one ground state you still couldn't
you'd have to know that the ground
state's generated
that as well
i didn't care
i was just thinking that you would need
to know well you need to know that crown
states are generous so if you had one
ground state you still wouldn't you
you'd have yeah
just by knowing gamma is log 2 there are
three candidates you're right
what's the fusion
what's the definition of the gapless
phase
yeah so if you look at the energy
spectrum
um
so a gap phase
uh is if i can take a certain interval
so we think thinking of really infinite
systems here
i can take some energy interval where
the number of states within this
interval is some finite number
um
so for example over here it would be
four right i can find an energy window
where there's just four that's a gap so
it doesn't have to be unique but there
should be only a finite number of states
so in a gapless phase if i take any
finite energy interval in the limit of a
very large system
uh you'll have a number of states that
scales
in some way with the system size
um so there are essentially an infinite
number of states within a finite small
interval um
sorry so
if you have a gap space then you define
them as you can connect this to every
point without closing the gap right
then you're in the same gap space that's
right yeah
then what's the how are different
gapless
that's a good question yeah yeah
so of course you don't have any
requirements about
keeping a spectral gap open
right but
you know there are you can still
characterize the phase by the physics
that there's the properties at very long
distances
for example if i look at a correlation
function with of two local operators a
large separation
uh it will have some fall-off even in a
gapless phase now typically it will be a
power law but the exponent of the power
is going to be fixed
uh you know so that's a characteristic
of the phase
now if you tune parameters that exponent
can change
and typically what happens that exponent
stays the same for a while and then
suddenly changes
so those are some really looking at long
distance properties is what
characterizes the state whether it's gap
to gapers
okay